in this video we'll be talking about
p-53 and its role in cell cycle
regulation
p-53 is a particular tumor suppressor
protein which can pause the cell cycle
p-53 plays key role in regulation of the
cell cycle apoptosis and maintenance of
genomic
stability so question is why does p 53
pause the cell cycle
progression why it should pause the cell
cycle how it can pause the cell cycle
and finally what is the
consequence so we would understand all
of this in this video p-53 is activated
in response to DNA damage imagine there
is a double stranded DNA break like this
one and double stranded DNA break is the
most cytotoxic because if unrepaired
these kind of doubl stranded DNA break
would have delorious effects like
blocking the replication even one
segment of the chromosome could be lost
during segregation and the ultimate
thing that can happen is death of these
cells so obviously when p-53 is mutated
none of these process can happen and
there is accumulation of mutation that
is why sometime p-53 is known as the
guardian of the
genome now let's see how p53 works so
DNA damage is sensed by several sensor
proteins such as ATM or ATR kyes ATM
stands for Axia thangum mutated but any
way these are Skyes which send the
double stranded DNA break and activates
another Downstream Target known as check
2 kyes check to phosphates
p53 once it is
phosphorilated the degradation of p-53
is prevented how is that in general
there is a protein known as mdm2 which
binds to p53 and uqu annihilates it for
degradation so obviously the
phosphorilated p53 is released from mdm2
and it cannot be degraded so when it
persist in the cells then p-53 can do
many things p-53 can activate
p21 and ultimately leading to inhibition
of cyclan cdk complex p21 is also known
as cki or cycline dependent kyes
Inhibitors so when cycl cdk complexes
are inhibited the cell cycle progression
is halted so now we see how the DNA
damage is sensed and how that is that
information is related to p-53 and what
p-53 does at a molecular level to pause
the cell cycle so obviously the
consequence is cell cycle pause now once
the cell cycle pause what really happens
so one sometimes pausing the cell cycle
is necessary to repair the DNA damage
that is the first and foremost thing
that cell would try cell would engage
homologous recombination based repair
system or non-homologous enjoining to
repair this kind of double strand DNA
brakes and if the DNA is repaired then
it's a very good sign cell cycle can
resume
again but imagine a situation when the
damage is
not uh repairable it's irrepairable
irreversible damage it is beyond repair
in that case p-53 coordinates with the
intrinsic pathway of apoptosis and
triggers the death of the cell it is
better to kill the
cell instead of segregating faulty or
mutate or accumulating
mutations so basically the p-53 mediated
pathway ultimately activates caspases so
basically p-53 produces bcl2 family of
sensors these bcl2 family proteins such
as back and bad poke holes in the
mitochondrial membrane which lead to a
leak of cytochrome c cytochrome c along
with apff 1 ultimately activates caspas
3 so inactive caspas 3 gets cleaved into
active caspas 3 and C caspace lead to a
DNA damage and digestion of many of the
cellular enzymes breakdown of nucleus
Etc it's important to note that there
are inhibitory C there are inhibitory
arm in this signaling for example bcl2
and B BCL XL are pro anti-apoptotic and
p-53 is kind of override this kind of
signal and preventing uh them to rescue
the cell anyway the cell would blip out
and the BBS would be uh cleared by the
macras so this tells us how DNA damage
when irreversible and irreparable can
trigger an intrinsic pathway of
apoptosis okay now we learned in this
video that there are two outcomes of p53
mediated cell cycle pause one is fixing
that damage with the help of
recombination based repair or on nhj and
resume the cell cycle now if this is
beyond repair then apoptosis and all
this thing was necessary because it is
better to have a dead cell than a cell
having faulty chromosome and having
mutations that might transform into a
cancer cell who knows so obviously pf53
mutations are highly associated with
many and most of the cancers the genomic
uh sequencing has found out there are
several mutation hotspot present in the
p53 gene which are always associated
with all types of cancers so that is why
p-53 is really important in context of
cell cycle regulation and cancer
progression I hope this video was useful
if you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up you can get more notes and
flash card in our Facebook page and
Instagram page the links are provided in
the description you can support our
Channel using super thanks you can pay
via PTM PayPal or UPI see you in next
video